[Music]
if you know an older left-handed person
chances are they had to learn to write
or eat with their right hand and in many
parts of the world it's still common
practice to force children to use their
proper hand even the word for right also
means correct or good not just in
English but many other languages too but
if being left-handed is so wrong then
why does it happen in the first place
today about one tenth of the world's
population are left-handed
archaeological evidence shows that it's
been that way for as long as five
hundred thousand years with about 10% of
human remains
showing the associated differences in
arm length and bone density and some
ancient tools and artifacts showing
evidence of left hand use and despite
what many may think handedness is not a
choice it can be predicted even before
birth based on the fetuses position in
the womb so if handedness is inborn does
that mean it's genetic well yes and no
identical twins who have the same genes
can have different dominant hands in
fact this happens as often as it does
with any other sibling pair but the
chances of being right or left-handed
are determined by the handedness of your
parents in surprisingly consistent
ratios if your father was left-handed
but your mother was right-handed you
have a 17% chance of being born
left-handed while to righties will have
a left-handed child only 10% of the time
handedness seems to be determined by a
roll of the dice but the odds are set by
your genes all of this implies there's a
reason that evolution has produced this
small proportion of lefties and
maintained it over the course of
millennia and while there have been
several theories attempting to explain
why handedness exists in the first place
or why most people are right-handed a
recent mathematical model suggests that
the actual ratio reflects a balance
between competitive and cooperative
pressures on human evolution
the benefits of being left-handed are
clearest in activities involving an
opponent like combat or competitive
sports for example about 50% of top
hitters in baseball have been
left-handed why think of it as a
surprise advantage because lefties are a
minority to begin with both right-handed
and left-handed competitors will spend
most of their time in countering and
practicing against righties so when the
two faced each other the left-hander
will be better prepared against this
right-handed opponent while the righty
will be thrown off this fighting
hypothesis where an imbalance in the
population results in an advantage for
left-handed fighters or athletes is an
example of negative frequency dependent
selection but according to the
principles of evolution groups that have
a relative advantage tend to grow until
that advantage disappears if people were
only fighting and competing throughout
human evolution natural selection would
lead to more lefties being the ones that
made it until there were so many of them
that it was no longer a rare asset so in
a purely competitive world 50% of the
population would be left-handed but
human evolution has been shaped by
cooperation as well as competition and
cooperative pressure pushes handedness
distribution in the opposite direction
in golf where performance doesn't depend
on the opponent only 4% of top players
are left-handed an example of the wider
phenomenon of tool sharing just as young
potential golfers can more easily find a
set of right-handed clubs many of the
important instruments that have shaped
society were designed for the
right-handed majority because lefties
are worse at using these tools and
suffer from higher accident rates they
would be less successful in a purely
cooperative world eventually
disappearing from the population so by
correctly predicting the distribution of
left-handed people in the general
population as well as matching data from
various sports the model indicates that
the persistence of lefties as a small
but stable minority reflects an
equilibrium that comes from competitive
and cooperative effects playing out
simultaneously over time and the most
intriguing thing is what the numbers can
tell us about various populations from
the skewed distribution of podna s' in
cooperative animals to the slightly
larger percentage of lefties in
competitive hunter-gatherer societies we
may even find that the answers to some
puzzles of early human evolution are
already in our hands
[Music]